As a child growing up in Barbados,
there were two things
I can count on every summer:
school break and the hurricane season.
At some point, we would go
through this whole routine
of duct-taping and all the glass doors
in these big X patterns,
tightly boarding up all the windows,
except for one or two --
so that, as my mother
would curiously put it,
we could let the wind come through.
And putting buckets
in the living room to catch the rain
in a futile attempt
to stop our house from flooding
when the roof started to billow
and sag in the wind.
I hated it.
Because I was terrified the entire time,
whether it was a tropical wave,
a thunderstorm, a tropical storm
or the tail-end of an actual hurricane
that barely missed us.
It was all the same to me.
A possible end.
No light, no water, no electricity,
just a simple battery-operated radio
waiting for the "all clear."
And in my young eyes,
Mother Nature on a personal mission
to destroy us all.
I never understood why.
Why, if we knew this was going
to happen every year,
why couldn't we just do something
to make sure that we were safer?
Why did I always have to put
out buckets and hide?
Fast forward to where we are now,
living through a burgeoning climate crisis
where my childhood fears
have quickly become my adult reality.
Just last year,
my country started
to experience freak storms
like none we had ever seen before.
This is a video of one such event.
Now, this is a real-time capture,
it is not sped up,
there are no special effects.
This system seemingly
materialized out of nowhere.
Typically, we'd have advance warning,
but this time, there was none.
We did not know this was coming
until it was right on top of us.
Imagine being jolted out of your sleep
to be greeted by this:
500 strikes of lightning per minute,
thunder and rain so loud,
it felt like it was coming
from the guts of the Earth.
The sky looked like
a firework display with no pauses.
And while we were still reeling
from the impacts of this event,
just a few weeks later,
another one hit us.
This time a Category 1 hurricane.
It destroyed over 2,000 homes.
Unpredictable events like this
are quickly becoming the norm.
And in a small country like mine,
of less than 300,000 people
and a mere land area
of just 166 square miles,
small numbers, small events
still mean big loss.
So for us,
who are already living through some
of the repercussions of climate change,
it is simply no longer enough
for architecture
to be beautifully passive.
In the face of these
looming new realities,
we need to create architecture
that genuinely performs.
So that's what I do.
I’m an architectural designer,
and I create structures
that have a deep reverence
and awareness of nature,
yet protect us from it.
I draw on those deceptively
simple micro lessons
that we as communities
have been inspired by over the years
that dealt with how we traditionally
handle the environment
and how we, rather than fighting
to keep nature out,
learned how to harness it
and embrace it for a shelter.
Now, I'm sure there are countless examples
of traditional building methodologies
that have stood the test of time
and weather.
Stories of inherent resilience.
But I want to share with you
a story from my own country,
one that has shaped my perspective
as I lived through
and designed for our changing
climate reality.
After the abolition of the enslavement
of African and Indigenous
peoples in Barbados,
my ancestors, newly freed,
couldn't just go and find land
to build their homes.
Their lands, unlike them,
were still property or "chattel"
of the former enslavers.
So out of this conundrum
the Bajan chattel house was born.
Chattel houses were modest homes
built entirely of timber,
with no nails mind you,
and sat on tightly packed coral stone.
The dilemma was that they
had to be robust enough
to survive the harsh temperaments
of our tropical weather,
yet somehow temporary,
so that inevitably,
when there was some kind of "dispute"
between a former enslaver
and a newly freed man or woman,
he or she could quickly grab
a couple of friends and family,
pack up and move
at a moment's notice for safety.
So how?
How, despite being so
low-tech and temporary,
could these endemic designs survive
often to see another day?
Unlike many of the more established,
robust and permanent homes.
Well, since these were made from whatever
timber was readily available,
there were no fancy
proprietary systems used.
So rather than trying to create
some kind of impenetrable force field
against the wind,
we had to get creative and figure out
how to work with the wind
instead of against it.
And when the wind is blowing
at incredible force against a home
that simply does not have
the adequate means to brace itself,
options are limited.
Gets kind of simple.
Like my mother used to tell me,
you let the wind come through.
Now, the trick to doing this lies
unexpectedly in the arrangement
of the timber facade,
with windows such as these
called "jalousie" windows.
And a quick side note,
jalousie actually comes
from the French word “jalousie”
meaning "jealousy."
So originally,
these angled horizontal slats
called louvers
were meant to keep jealous,
peering eyes from seeing into your home.
But architecturally,
what they did was allow wind
to filter through
while still keeping rain out.
So these intentionally aligned apertures
would allow you to open all the slats
on the windows and doors
to literally let
the hurricane pass through,
channeling that wind through
the building's interior,
instead of building up
destructive pressure on the facade.
The result was that the weather,
as I might say, if I was at home,
“might ’lick down ya house,
but it aint gine mash it up.”
Translation for those who need it:
the compound effect
of these micro solutions
was a house that might ...
it might bend,
but it wouldn't totally break.
Drawing on examples such as this,
I quickly realized that as a region,
we really need to depart
from this more global convention
of designing our buildings
to close themselves off from nature
so that architecture, for us,
becomes less about
the external expression,
aesthetic and shape of the building,
but more about its holistic performance
in concert with the environment.
Like those jalousie windows,
it's about those micro solutions,
those little details that quite literally
make or break a building.
For example,
after the passage of Hurricane Maria
through the Caribbean in 2017,
many properties suffered devastating loss.
As designers,
we were faced with that
now common question:
How do we build back better?
The answer?
Simple.
You take what works, discard what doesn't,
and apply it to modern designs.
In one instance,
the wind-dispersing capabilities
of those traditional louvers
became a modern interpretation.
So my team and I at the time
designed a timber fin facade
that would do the same thing:
break up the wind
against the building's exterior
while still allowing light to penetrate
to the building's interior,
all while protecting the exposed
glass from wind
and wind driven missiles.
So no more duct tape.
In another instance,
we designed a sacrificial central core
that allowed wind to penetrate
through the interior of the building
while preserving adjacent,
locked-down watertight bunkers zones
for people to retreat
from the wind and the rain.
So no more buckets.
And many of my colleagues
in island nations, such as my own,
are in the process of integrating
this similar strategy
of taking traditional designs
and applying them to modern approaches.
And this is not just limited
to hurricanes,
but address issues such as floods,
earthquakes, landslides,
where traditional, stilted designs
help to keep us elevated
above torrential downpour and inundation
and where cross-brace lattice elements
make sure our buildings
are flexible enough
to withstand the Earth moving
and shaking beneath them.
We are at a point now where we model
an intelligent digital twin
of each design in virtual reality.
Think of it as a sort of computerized 3D
carbon copy of each micro solution,
so that we can stress-test it.
We can throw real-world
climate scenarios its way.
And because we’re in that
virtual environment,
there's no loss of human life,
there's no costly
damage to infrastructure,
and we can pick a building apart
and figure out what it actually takes
to make a more resilient structure.
We can, say, throw a Category 5
hurricane wind simulation its way,
and if it fails in that safe
environment, we can fix it.
We can tweak it, we can improve it,
we can optimize the design,
and we can do that iteratively
until we get it right.
And because we have started
from these Indigenous references,
we end up with well-performing,
modern, yes,
but accessible architecture
that is not alien to its cultural
or climatic context.
Architecture that is not alien --
(Applause)
Architecture that is not alien
to the people who must build
and live in it.
Architecture that by testing
and design is more resilient
as we prepare for harsher weather.
Now, I've said a lot.
But nothing ...
Nothing prepares you
for the mental uncertainty
of experiencing, and hopefully
living through, a hurricane.
That feeling of total vulnerability.
Of being fully exposed to the elements
and at the absolute mercy ...
of nature.
The sound of the wind
ripping a building to pieces.
The sound of your neighbors’
screams being carried away
in that same wind.
The “What if?”
"What if they don't make it?"
"What if we don't make it?"
"What if I don't make it?"
"What if?"
But what if we could design away
some of that uncertainty
and shelter in place
with a sense of confidence
that we have given ourselves
the best chance at surviving,
the best chance at weathering each storm?
Across the world, as humans,
we are doing amazing things.
We are putting people
into space for leisure.
(Applause)
We are searching and figuring out
how to live in and survive
the extremes of distant
planetary climates.
Yes, that's amazing.
However, on this planet,
so many of us still live in constant fear
that the next event will be the big one
that either dramatically changes
or outright claims our existence here
on planet Earth forever.
You've probably heard this
a million times,
but we as small island nations
are living in our present,
the future that you all
are poised to face.
So we need to know now what works
and what does not
in our specific contexts,
because it is a true, immediate,
cyclical matter of life and death for us.
So.
As we step into this new era,
as we design and build our future
cities and communities,
the approach, again, is so simple.
We must do so no longer leaving the most
vulnerable of us to guess
and hope for the best.
But based on tried,
tested, traditional knowledge
and lived experience,
designing for the absolute worst.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)